السلطات الاسرائيليه تفرج عن عدد من
المعتقلين الذين اعتقلوا خلال الحرب
الدائره على قطاع غزه بعد ان تعرضوا
لتعذيب قاس واجراءات تعسفيه ظهرت جليه على
اجساد هؤلاء الذين وصلوا الى مشفى الشهيد
ابو يوسف النجار هنا في مدينه رفح جنوب
قطاع غزه البعض منهم كما تشاهدون للاسف
الشديد في مشهد مبكي مؤلم قاسي جدا حتى لا
يستطيعون التحدث هنا محاوله ل فاقه احد
هؤلاء الذين و صل في حاله صحيه يرثى لها
تعرضوا للتعذيب في الاقدام في الايدي في
الدماغ في الظهر في البطن كافه انحاء
الجسد كانت قد تعرضت من قبل القوات
الاسرائيليه للضرب وسحل وشبح وصنوف
التعذيب المختلفه كنت مركب انا بلاتين في
الطرق ولانه كان عندي ثلاث
قصور بلاتين هذا
داخلي عندي ضربه في
راسي شعر في الجمجم
والحمد لله يعني كنت لتحت علاج يعني فلما
انا اخذني الجيش وخلاني اطمر راسي على
الارض قاللي طمر راسك ما بتفاجئ الا
الجندي بالبسطار صار يرفعني من رقبتي هيك
ويخبط ني
ورا اكثر من اربع خمس ضربات حسيت حالي
غيبت يعاودوا يصحوني يسحبني عاود ينزلني
ويخبط ني
بالبسطار على المنطقه من ورا ح شي
فك اخذونا في الجبات رمونا في جبات حديد
طبعا ونقلنا على منطقه يمكن هي دقيت على
ما اعتقد حطونا بين سواتر بمخيم للجيش
حملونا حملان خبطو في الارض حطونا في جوره
وطم علينا وفلت الكلاب علينا وصاروا يدعس
على وجوهنا ويضربوا فينا احنا الثلاثه انا
ومعي شبين صغار ظلينا تقريبا يمكن ما
يقارب لمنتصف الليل بعد هيك اجوا قالوا
لنا قوموا في السقع طبعا احنا عريانين
قومو وحطوه على لوح دكت و حطونا على الواح
دكت بعد هيك بعرفش قالوا لنا يلا تشاهدوا
بدنا نعدم ه بنا نطخ طخك قلنا لهم الموت
لسه اشرف قاعدون على ركبنا وطب يضربوا
فينا ويخطو في الكشنات وفي البواريد وفي
العصي بهدلونا ما بعد هيك اخذونا في جبات
كمان مره ونقلو على موقع ثاني نفس الحكي
بعد هيك بعد ما ضربونا لبسونا بولات بيض
وقالوا لنا هدول بدكم نعدكم هديت فيهم
قلنا لهم عد مونا نقلونا كمان على موقع
بعد الموقع هذا لبسونا الزيه هذا الاب هول
ودخلوه على كمبيوترات وصورو ودخلوه اللي
هو على بركسات
مفتوحه و40 يوم نا روايات تقشعر لها
الابدان وتشيب لها الرؤوس عرفنا منها
القليل على لسان هؤلاء والكثير منها مازال
غامضا مع الاف من المعتقلين في السجون
الاسرائيليه اعتقلوا خلال الحرب الدائره
على قطاع غزه هاني الشاعر قناه الجزيره
مدينه رفح